there are major outbreaks of corona
virus in Japan South Korea in Italy in
Japan all schools are closed for the
next month at least and yet the United
States is still receiving flights from
all three of those countries in fact we
aren't even screening arrivals for the
virus congresswoman and Democratic
presidential candidate Tulsi Gabbard of
Hawaii says that needs to change she
joins us tonight : thanks so much for
coming on
so thanks Leigh there's an economic cost
to shutting down routes or to
inconveniencing passengers do you think
we need to do it anyway tell us why we
do because first of all let's let's look
at the first move that was taken by the
Trump administration to suspend flights
coming from China to protect the safety
and health and well-being of the
American people to prevent the spread of
of coronavirus here to our shores
similarly this is what needs to happen
with Japan South Korea and Italy these
other countries who are going through a
serious outbreak that they are dealing
with and like you said there is still no
screening taking place not only on
arrival with people coming here but what
I think needs to be done as people
should be tested before they get on the
plane in that case and in that instance
if people are tested they come out
negative then they can go about their
business this this will have some some
economic impact there's no doubt about
it but that impact in the short term now
by taking this action will pale in
comparison to the economic hardship and
challenges we'll face in this country if
these flights are allowed to continue
people are coming here potentially
infected with this virus and then it is
allowed to continue to spread the
hardship on the lives of the American
people and the hardship on our economy
will be far-reaching and longer-lasting
so just to put this in context for our
viewers you represent of course the
state of Hawaii which I would bet has
more direct flights to Asia than any
other place in the United States it's a
major source of revenue for your state
and so this would mean Hawaii takes a
big hit but you're still in favor of it
that's how concerned you are we have to
have foresight and recognize the
priority for our leaders is to ensure
the safety and health
well being of the people of my home
state of Hawaii the people of our
country and taking this step now is
necessary to be able to accomplish that
because if we don't then it's too late
then the the coronavirus may have
already taken root and again you're
looking at impact on jobs impact on
schools impact YES on a state like ours
that's heavily dependent on tourism that
will be far far more long-lasting and
devastating no that's right so what
would you say I mean this is a
conversation that's kind of popped up a
couple of times in the last week but
each time it does the people who raise
it or denounced as xenophobic how would
you respond to that it's looking at the
facts and and looking at the reality
unfortunately there has been some
xenophobia around this outbreak that
began in China that must be denounced
really what we're talking about is the
the United States the American people as
well as how small this global community
is and how essential it is that we work
with other countries to be able to
prevent this from becoming an all-out
pandemic and so look I want to make a
direct appeal to President Trump at this
point to break through the bureaucracy
break through the red tape that we're
seeing from agencies like the CDC and
the FDA in order to broaden the testing
criteria to make it so that anyone who
has symptoms can actually get a test and
to make sure that these tests are
readily available whether it's in a
doctor's office in a hospital at our
airports or even as they're doing in
countries like Scotland and South Korea
have there's a drive-through station you
can go in and get the tests and be in
and out in less than 10 minutes rather
than having the kind of prolonged
testing that we're having now where the
CDC only tests a very few people because
of their narrow criteria and then you've
gotta wait four days if you're one of
those people who gets tested potentially
if you have the virus putting you in a
place where you're exposing other people
and putting them at risk we've got it
we've got to get on the ball on this
it's it seems like it seems like a
no-brainer for sure congressman thank
you so much for saying that you're one
of the few appreciate it